in 50 49 48 let me know counts down
count is down from a million Erin okay
welcome 52 another special episode of
the trunk ah Steve Rannazzisi is here
everybody we've already done like an
hour's worth of a podcast God but I've
been writing down everything I want to
retake about live Johnny's here Aaron's
here
baseball's in full swing you're Aaron
you said Cardinals suck dick right
no just currently not great Yankees we
uh ha we run a nine-game winning streak
we lost us today the warrior Knights
right yeah I went to something that's
gained a lot of balls going bye-bye okay
Gary Sanchez hit by the way angels
talking about my sex life I've had it oh
sorry I didn't realize you're gonna
start that process again no Cubs dude
okay fine yeah have a game um probably
ish out of first that's fine only
because we've had eight games no doubt
yeah look at the Braves 16 and 11 yet
come to right 1710 where the Cubs right
now 16 and 10 yeah 16 okay well yeah
well we're chasing a phenomenon we gotta
stay pretty close to Boston we're only
two maybe three games back it's exciting
tripolis running a little late ari we
may or may not get a hold of Ari today
he was into the idea of you being here
because we have to discuss and we'll
save this yeah I am the Louie CK does
rumors he's been doing spot rumors
nothing rumors are not easy either he
did it or he didn't well do you know the
bets over it's not over and you think
it's not over a hundred percent not over
well Sam last night was telling me a
hundred percent also over a hundred
percent it is over
that's what conspiracy Johnson thinks no
there's no conspiracy either he stepped
on stage or he didn't step on stage all
right one of the two things happened
well we'll discuss that in a little bit
but here's what I want to discuss right
now before we get an NFL draft and all
this other [ __ ] that we have to do I
want to talk to you about this little
thing that you're trying to be which is
the Steinbrenner of nine-year-olds yeah
this is ridiculous III saw the flyer and
I've been seeing you but we week or
something right I saw you when you were
leaving the other it yeah but we haven't
hung out in a while
a couple weeks and I saw that one you
were at a game you went to Dodgers yank
correct not right angels Sunday yeah saw
the fan when today out and then I said
somebody sent me a flower and I saw that
we're on the same show Thursday mm-hmm
and you me Theo was like one of those
shows yeah a bunch of my buddies on that
he's at the store right no it said that
the sycamore Tavern oh yeah yeah yeah
but it's like 8 o'clock
you mean the a bunch of people and I was
like oh that's a cool show it's a bunch
of my buddies which is rare yeah
and then the guy goes Oh Brenna's easy
might not make it
he's running a little league Ponzi
scheme no no scheme it's a triangle what
is the pyramid it's a pyramid you're my
triangle but no he says because you're
you're kids playing Little League yes
I'm so small Thor I know both of your
kids both of them are they on that note
on the scene on the same T and one is 9
so he's in a 9 to 11 that he's the
youngest of the there's there's fifth
graders there's third fourth and fifth
graders in there he's on the younger
side okay so he is physically smaller
than most of them these kids throw 50
okay 50 miles an hour okay on average
yeah 50s about high but never fear-o
your order just choked up on a bat just
crack them no I mean these kids are okay
yeah well they can never they're not
gonna strike me out that's what I'm
saying but be fun to just Jack a bunch
of homers I do i do pitch to them BP and
then sometimes I'll lay it in a lot
harder yeah well if you so much yeah
well they start ripping it down the
third base line what I got I said who's
you know set a precedent here that we
can't run all over coach Steve yeah so
you know I'll I'll Brody Stevens in a
little bit and just you know drop it a
little bit come off the me also mention
what I'll a closer mound it's a little
closer than an adult should be yeah it's
fine so you're really it you know you if
you amp it up you're throwing like 120
at these guys home it's like 85 from
that class yeah
no but it did these okay so now Yuri
games a week are you cut what coaching
no there is a coach I'm an assistant
coach okay so I technically don't have
to be but no one really
even the coach doesn't have to be there
we were some one of us is there all the
time it but it is a lot like it's three
games a week plus a practice three games
three games a week and make it steel now
there are you know we're talking double
plays you're talking to ten hours ten
hours a week that's that's one comedy
that's your job you had hell way more
wow I'm on I'm on you job I'm on a
Little League field longer than I'm
onstage all week for sure yeah easily
hundred percent do you try to run any
bits with the kids is that no no they
some of them know what I do
have you gotten bits yeah we're kidding
me yeah I had a whole bit my last album
about Little League when I was coaching
the Little League everyone capes my son
one to her cape okay and then half his
team wore capes the games and then we
played up it's the whole thing yeah have
you seen that little kid that runs
really slow to a home that's a funny
video yeah I just saw that like that
coach told this kid hey run as fast as
you can from third home and he goes so
slow like he's little doing slow-motion
and then the coach keeps going like
speeded up speed and everybody's
laughing so hard and then when he
finally gets to home does he slide but
in slow motion he just kind of falls on
and he can't before he can't before
years old over the assumption is that he
thinks slow motion on TV is real all
right yeah yeah this is the greatest
[ __ ] and he goes get home as fast as you
can look dad here he goes oh that's not
it this is really how the guy walking in
the background is great for reference
look at this [ __ ] his helmet is so big
on him it's so funny see that that's my
other sons team that's the that's the
equivalent of wearing capes and you said
they all want to know where it came so
I'm like oh yeah that's about that's it
yeah come on here we go buddy here we go
pick it up he's will break it out off me
right back to it I've been preparing for
this moment for years like whole life
whole life has led to talk and if you're
gonna stand up stand up or slide down
Jimmy down down down okay
I'll slide no big deal
and here we go in a swipe tag
love it dude that's literally that's the
sound of 30 parents hysterically
laughing is the audio of yeah it's 30
parents they're funny dude hysterically
laughs my my yahoo war cave my youngest
is now this is a second-year t-ball so
he's at the point where he's done with
this tea so he'll walk up his half his
team you needs the tea so he'll walk up
he'll take the ball off the tee kick the
tea over throw the ball a hundred miles
an hour to the coach that's at the
pitcher's mound and go and because this
yeah crushes the ball does he really
yeah he is bigger too which one is a
better at athletics or is it one cannon
canter
here's my oldest is having a tougher
time is here because he's the youngest
in that age group so there are kids that
are in fifth grade that are like you
know that throat so and my youngest is
in the older group like he's the older
so he has no fear right now but I think
that he's the one that would go up he
would walk up to my younger one will
walk up to to a kid that's on my other
sons team you'll throw it at me I'll hit
it no problem yeah he's very lair both
my two cousins who are in there you know
late 20s now early 30s but when they
were in high school they were both
incredible baseball players and they're
at the same age difference and they both
got scholarships like played college
ball sometime one year together and then
three years apart but I remember my
uncle who played minor league ball Pete
Rose he actually died of Lou Gehrig's
disease
my uncle Gary he was like we were just
talking me and him having beers just
talking and the kids then Gary and Jeff
were probably 15 you know like that was
about the mean of their age and I'm like
you know they're both killing Little
League killing Little League and in
early high school ball and I'm like
who's better at what and he's like I
mean Gary's a better hitter but Jeff
would rather get murdered doesn't let a
[ __ ] ball get by a shortstop and I
was like okay cuz now you've watched
them yeah you know it doesn't mean you
do you love more it's like who you know
a scout yeah yeah don't be a dad and you
know he was a coach and he played you
know almost went pro yeah so he would be
like hey this is basically what it you
know if you want me to not be a dad
I love it both but if I may not be a dad
I don't think there's a pro and either
one of my son's careers really no no
already I don't I mean is that the Kate
was it the capes was that your that was
the older one side I mean I don't know
the younger ones still he said I can't
get a read a hundred percent on him but
yeah I don't know like you know it's fun
no huh it's so much fun now as it's just
like we're adding a base book and you
know what my older one now they're like
games now they play six inning games and
it's all the sudden it's like ground
ball double play whoa what was like
they're like money you gotta needs the
side acts a little side action there's a
game you're having score right Oh score
there's a whole app now called game
changer that you could follow stop stop
are you doing honest I swear to God I
will show you the app I I score the game
last night for example right so as I'm
scoring if I'm on the road my buddy does
the scoring on the app and I can listen
to the game so they have a feature where
like ground balls Jackson ran his ease
ease up ground ball to the shortstop and
he's out at first it's all at an
automated voice but it basically
whenever he scores the game oh [ __ ] look
who's here buddy
which you know who we're winners when
we're 20 minutes into it yeah 20 minutes
what are you in a 40-minute delay hang
on so so keep going and so I can listen
to the game as it's being scored right
like but but when you do it so that like
that's how to the app now the asset
accounts like does it use that money key
oh yeah like for this season I'm just
saying it because that's a brilliant
idea
but it keeps the stats for everyone it's
how like yeah which is what which is
also what makes everything else awful
because now coaches are cons so now yeah
both you have both kids that are placed
on pornhub how I wish dude don't worry
League Baseball changer last night's
scoring the game you know you flip over
Instagram yeah and then old son Sam's
feed comes up and it's probably some
[ __ ] [ __ ] just yeah going to tell my
babies everybody yells them yeah I know
it also like whoops not that ones that
sound so now are you doing is adopted
are you coaching both kids dude the
other ones like all hands on deck any
human being parent that's at a t-ball
game yeah if you're just sitting there
staring at it as a personal coach yeah
you got a kid has a cow it's like a farm
yeah yeah like every kid in the outfield
but yeah I'll go and prepare in
everybody having kids seven dads yeah
and if you're like the one parent or
just sitting there staring at us like
wrangling everyone else yeah and your
league did they do the thing where
everybody gets to play has to know okay
they don't that's good I mean like we
try we do that no you don't eat kids so
cuz parents can get pissy about fine
gambling
do you have children yeah it's a yes we
will have kids rotate and they'll sit
there like two or three kids see you
getting [ __ ] off parents yet for like no
I mean I gotta say I gotta say our team
literally is very very good the parents
are good we were like uh but I see my
coach first Bates sometimes I'll be the
first base coach yeah you can hear the
other [ __ ] were you talking analytics
with this we have you started doing in
game analytics no I'm saying there's an
app now is it there's an app called game
changer where that's how you that's yet
so you score the game there's no more
[ __ ] book so as the guy sits there's
and scores it like ball pit it doesn't
pitch by pitch you can do it's very easy
and I can be on the road and there's a
feature that I can it's like I'm
listening to the game like someone's
announcing it to me like an automated
voice like pitch one to Jackson around
as easy ball outside Wow yeah and if
it's long as he whatever he hits oh yeah
it's runner on first steal second you
know and you've also got like on-base
percentage for your everything and you
know everything pitch count even know my
batting average until I was fifteen
yeah pitch count all that [ __ ] I was
killed I couldn't hit and then one day I
just got it and then I got on base every
game that's Jackson's my older oldest
son he's he's the youngest in this
division he's really young for this
division and the first couple games he
was afraid to take the bat off his
shoulder and then now he's just you know
he'll ground ball fly ball couple hits
here and there I was a good left-handed
pitcher until like right around high
school and then I was like and you found
that
yeah I'm lefty too and I wish I stuck
with it cuz I've been approached I
didn't even realize that that was ad
what makes you think you could have been
a pro because I'm lefty five mile an
hour Jimmy key junk for the rest I
remember when my buddy
one of my buddies who played baseball in
high school and he had a baby we were
roommates in college he had a baby and
he goes I'm gonna tie this kid's right
hand behind his back
and cuz at least you can get a
scholarship you if you're a left-handed
semi-decent pitcher in high school you
have a free education if not go pro can
i go i was really good at sliding can
that keep me pro you really just slide
imagine you I can start sliding halfway
down just jump and just roll I remember
when I was like a playing Little League
and [ __ ] just like when you're like the
Cape yeah just I'm leading off on first
and I just remember looking at it was
like this squirrel that was in the
outfield I'm just looking at his
[ __ ] squirrel picked off
okay hits me I look at him like
[ __ ] what did you and he's got
the bottom yeah I can't have a
motorcycle I would die in a car crash
leaving the lock some lady brings her
[ __ ] parents haha to the field to
like you know parrots Paris
haha you know like the great so like
t-ball um you know try to compete with
[ __ ] Game of Thrones dragon over your
[ __ ] head the kids all the kids are
looking up in the air but it's not Jimmy
I see oh god you're not trained call our
parents though right mascot she's a
weird neighborhood you're like that's
her that's her five o'clock hour to go
[ __ ] walk my kid there no she's a
public park if a woman does that she's
crazy if a guy does that he's a
pedophile right oh yeah believe yeah go
hey she doin trick and she sits in the
corner with her [ __ ] burly yeah well
at the Pepperdine graduation I said you
see how to pelicans just came in where
is this at the Pepperdine University
graduate would they do what the pillars
flew in and then of course everybody got
like pissed and they're like it's
pushing the burnout like hey you know
you weren't invited to this wedding
never put the birds like [ __ ] you and it
biting back it was just like why are you
doing that to the [ __ ] pelican dude
do that what about this I'm sure you
guys talked about that that bald eagle
that landed on that Mariner yeah that
was great
Oh evil bald eagles are like right human
hands yeah made out of nine my god so
him land [ __ ] passively land on him he
probably cut his [ __ ] up pretty good
yeah I'm not good with birds like
pitchers are sighs I'm really good I was
fine we did this thing in the league one
time with his [ __ ] bird hat she you
know my daughter comes home with a pet
bird and it's supposed to attack me and
that we couldn't get the scene because
I'm I kept bailing out like it's
supposed to like they won the shot of
like over my shoulder and the bird
coming at me but this [ __ ] bird I
know is trained and it was tethered to
the thing but when it got when I got its
wings out it got really [ __ ] big and
it we got like me out and did it I think
it's got no soul and I did have a look
at insides like today that we had a bear
too and a bear I was more fun with the
bear than I was the bird we all have our
weird thing I don't like it I'll trust
we do have a weird yeah we've all got
something oh my god so it just
dive-bombed into the crowd yeah [ __ ]
yeah yeah these people feed you know
what my favorite what my favorite
episode of the league was and I've
literally watched every episode and I
loved that show give me your favorite my
favorite episode the next hour but my
favorite episode was um when you're the
when what is this Oh clean the mop out
sure God no is this chyron box set in
the oh are about levin wears a hat and
everything is like hey trivago guy and
we bring that beer down a street level
he's banging he's like I know where the
hotel room
actually this [ __ ] BAM oh my god
Phyllis Phyllis it's a pelican dude I
would be freaking out too man that's a
big [ __ ] bird dude this dude over
here just pushes it watch like this guy
yeah you just get a little slap I'm
gonna slap a pelicans like go [ __ ]
yourself homeboy yourself you do auto
gates dates yet no I was I was saying
what I my favorite episode was the one
when your daughter yeah Ellie yeah yeah
and then what's-his-name dress like that
character and he was just like [ __ ]
[ __ ] one's character giblets yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's the funniest about my
favorite one thank you when he pops up
out of the bushes what was your least
favorite was your Flo's the one you're
like [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] if I know
red is easier in the highway Matt Forte
because that episode map for tape just
[ __ ] me in fantasy and then I want to
turn on your [ __ ] and Forte was on there
knows I got this [ __ ] yeah he
did that was a hard one to watch because
I hated that him that day so you
couldn't jerk off dates arcades go ahead
okay that's what you tonight we have an
interesting show at the dojo
we have Bert Kreischer Whitney Cummings
Dane Cook they're all going up it's ten
bucks I don't know why I'm saying this
because this won't be out till tomorrow
right I will be June first at the iMac
where were you last night
I slept I did George anyways I'm going
to be June 1st at Cobbs I'm doing the
tinfoil hat conspiracy comedy night me
Eddie Bravo Trez Mela and we're off the
grid Ryan we're gonna be there June 1st
Cobbs and then June
second at the sacramental punchline how
let your boy you close your eyes for
that I had to think Steve what do you
know ya may I'm going to Charlotte what
does that window Oh
may 17 18 and 19th actually I'll be
there 16 - so Wednesday the 16th I'm
doing a charity event for Thomas Davis
charity the charity fund down there and
then 17 18th and 19th one show Thursday
to Friday to Saturday Charlotte comedy
zone come on out and I'm gonna try to
play Quail Hollow Country Club yes yes
with uh with a couple friends a couple
NFL guys out there named um lindomar a
former kicker of course last year the
national mean court McGowan had an out
there Trump national beautiful
coral/orange
bleh yes big Lee thing could be out here
you have to hit it big area but in bag
no big Lee is my favorite word that
truck uses you should get out a pie
nurse while you're there man
I played there before but I do the
Raleigh like Raleigh North Carolina run
I do that Pinehurst that was fun
what's yours what you're my buddy you
work there this is what I'm announcing
it scored zero zero point zero he's that
good I think he's a zero or one I'm
announcing I'm gonna Senior Tour fifty
years old I'm gonna go pro I have nine
years ago if you couldn't go in pitching
you gotta go in golf that's it I say
yeah I could play that till I'm 100
now hold on your be in the Senior Tour
and not done the regular tour yeah
do you be like I finally got this yeah
sure I'll be at the comedy dojo this
Thursday night and with you and yeah oh
you got a Vaughn Vaughn I started that
room and thank you Sycamore right yeah
it's a play it's a workout room cool
comedy story
that's the dates out the gates everybody
go ahead I already did it no no fake
ones no no yeah I thought you were at
the chuckle ha yeah how about the finger
glass this way parties they're all gone
no parties did the part you know what I
got kicked out of party did I think I
knew managers what happened well I like
I wasn't party enough no I did morning
radio do you think that Tiffany hatch
brings back her classic queefing where
she put some I got her snatch know and
she queefs I wouldn't put a pastor I
thought she did that an SNL opening
monologue I'm ready
how did you ever see that bit that Sarah
Silverman did she don't like I'm not
special but it sounded like you know she
was like doing this big musical number
and then like her vagina was playing
like a bunch of really yeah it's really
funny but seen it yeah I mean it's
better than if you were queefing she
literally did a set word like she did
her set and some guy fingered her the
whole time in like mangy [ __ ] yeah yeah
a special set in Montreal which which
one uh Tiffany or Silverman Silverman
hmm wait hold on
she did a headliner set yeah she's do
this at you get her so the audience knew
that she was getting fingered yeah
during the whole time there's a curtain
in front of I think so Kyle Dunnigan is
below her who ever know I don't know I'm
guessing but whoever it is like her
boyfriend or just a random guy I don't
know all the specifics I just heard the
urban legend oh it's an urban so this
could also not be true very much oh I
got us plead with I don't know if this
is true or not do i yeah you're really
shitty wise baby I'm here because I
don't want to run the logistics on this
thing so now the curtain lights ladies
and gentlemen Sarah Silverman friends
are there we live right and then she's
standing there hey what's up guys this
could be a little bit of a stranger
anyway what's up an airplane food
guys oh yeah keep fingering me and
that's it and then you know and
sometimes I like
hey you know what I'm gonna lean towards
this actually is not true [ __ ] is this
no no no there's no big comedy as you
know and can you make your big this is
breaking news with Orissa fear ah who's
agreed to direct this game of a big ape
or announcement on we have a gay porn on
the line okay whether Louie does is set
in a year or not by the end of December
31st yep
of this year yep thousand 18 that's the
performance thin of Communists and who
has agreed to direct this gay porn one
and only mr. Neal Brennan
Netflix director Neal Brennan I taught
you that last night how do you for
someone that looks at his phone so much
you never read your Jack's did you
really I did I say that was bad yeah
yeah why would it be really to said that
it's real you didn't read Neal Brennan
will direct the porn now obviously we
have to work around his schedule and and
yours and Ari's yeah and whatever gay
porn stars we happen again now can I get
like a bit part in this now that he's oh
just a few lines I I thought about my
version of it I've not stopped thinking
about my version of it yeah it's kind of
fun really is and I hope you're not
three pages now how much do you fear the
version of you being in it I've never
once thought about that right I've never
once thought about that and every day
that goes by I imagine everybody was
blowing out a hand is [ __ ] some sort
of articles
I don't read Hollywood reply back so he
heard that he's done it he is first of
all I blossom Sarah Silverman queex of
nine straight hours on stage and the
earth is flat and Chewbacca is the
president
you just pitch this is tinfoil nod cast
I know which highly successful but I'm
not gonna go to you as a stret news
source I'm very happy to learn I'm very
happy for your podcast too but whenever
Sam starts a sentence with I've actually
heard the rest of it is just this to me
yes exactly
if you've actually heard done well and
I've lost the bet then let's start that
show me the proof I could I could not
find the proof under it wouldn't I think
it would be on sway at least somebody
would tweet like now I know I have
spoken re about it he's gone to comedy
clubs he sat there he's hung out he
hangs out he's gonna go goes an old
saying in recovery you hang out in a
barber shop long enough you're gonna get
a haircut he's if he's hanging out clubs
it's just a matter he may even do it at
the end of the night when everybody's
left and there's a couple people left
question be like hey can I just go up so
that's what we do know as truth he's
been hanging out at baby he's been seen
at clubs right yes time out now okay I
already know here that if you actually
gone way to go Aaron I've heard he's out
on the street barking such a dump look
at this art look at this headline maybe
seek a path to come back likely runs
through comedy clubs well of course if I
hadn't Artem that was also his path to
heart oh this is just click page bronze
LeBron James path back to the NBA Finals
goes through the debate how we're not
debating on whether or not he's going to
come through comedy club of course it's
just whether or not when he's going to
do or do you think that The Hollywood
Reporter wrote this in reference to the
bet like just so the world wants to know
look at this line this is from the
County saw guy he says he predicts CK
will return within a year yeah within a
year I know it's right on the board
December 31st 3018 real quick couple
things I forgot what I was gonna say
okay Shawn Pat that always Wow what just
happened right hand
real quick a couple things you had
several things you wanted to say forgot
all of that weight patents lorries in
Australia I wouldn't be surprised
are they oh I wouldn't be surprised if
he came back tomorrow
Ari Shaffir definitely before December
31st 100% can I write this article blues
that's uh yeah he's pressuring it yeah
Sean Patti echoes the notion saying the
only way comes back you have many
sources but not saying a lot oh now I
remember it you know I think the new
Lucy Kay is he's gonna be the new one
Tom Segura I do I think not not sexually
term Oh getting into that era where it's
like he's putting out specials all the
time and he's he's create I think he's
gonna fill that void oh well I saw you
meant like he was like I was like Jesus
he's right all right I don't know how
much I didn't mean like going to crank
out like he's going to fill that void
comedic Lee oh yeah be wonderful oh my
god yeah I mean I've been watching him
like when he walks on stage the the it's
like people go [ __ ] nuts and then
like he walks out here's my new [ __ ] and
it's boom boom boom but I'm like holy
[ __ ] dude like he is hitting right now
like I haven't seen somebody you know
like Bert Kreischer is there too but tom
has got Commons like really like I mean
I brought bird up your the fact this is
so bad the birth but they're supposed to
bring up Ali Wong whatever I don't know
if she was there when I went onstage she
wasn't there yet so then I'm done and I
go who's next Jeff and he goes huh you
thought it was Ali we've got a special
guest and I was like all right he gives
me a piece of paper which in the old
days used to be like chappal our name
it's Bert Kreischer I go I go where's
the where's the special guest there we
go
yes okay
[Music]
I think Oh ladies and gentlemen crusher
and he they went nuts and I mean I get
it totally but it's like it was so funny
I was like oh Bert Kreischer was a
special guest now he gets a big thing
about like they played that thing so
well like you know time versus Bert it
was the greatest
oh that's Segura though like cigars so
[ __ ] smart like he knows how to like
he's just like a [ __ ] he's really
smart
yeah good promoter and I got him in the
comedy Oh that's what we're doing here
all the drive here all the drive here
can I walk in kick over everyone's
sandcastles and make it about me oh I
got it I got it I got the boy really
nice compliments all yours
yep there it is yeah everybody garbage
person yes everybody
and guess who gave him his first drive
here to the Commish army he never would
have gotten there I mean it about a lot
of things great you are welcome you're
happy about the you're happy about your
draft oh my god I mean you're wearing
your rock and the giant respect it's do
an office you can water blessing it's a
quite healthy leave around to you I
think before you fell to us yeah knew
they were gonna [ __ ] that up you think
that the Browns are smart enough to know
that the draft besides me getting times
who are lookin Manziel 2.0 let's hear
how it's a Quan Barclay Oh Sam Tripoli
for his [ __ ] [ __ ] rare moment of
Wednesday the Jets
[ __ ] [ __ ] with the Browns because
they forever put out that there's this
weird kind of like oh yeah Jets a uh
they're pigs gonna be a Mayfield they're
like we're taking him he's gonna follow
us and we're gonna take them
and then boom down sit Donaldson falls
them like that so we wanted the whole
time I mean dude I'm sure there's poise
like that put out there oh absolutely
especially in the top yeah you know
actually you hear that much later
because there was all these rumors that
the Bears were trying to get Ridley who
the Falcons mine of the Falcon so
there's all these rumors of like you
hear who
and I was wondering who's the guy saying
that [ __ ] you're gonna mean who's the
guy that let you know is that it I think
so it's gotta be the agent who's this
guy who's the guy that lets out on every
single draft day the one or two things
that nobody ever wanted to find out
about like remember the the that was a
shitty balanced racist tweets when 12 14
or whatever it's like who's the guy that
like waits to the day of the draft
somebody every year it's the day of the
trick nobody finds that [ __ ] out on the
day of the draft for hours before
anybody that's going like hey we when
you you're about to make eight million
dollars twenty-one-year-old that I have
information on and I'm a scumbag
thousand dollars what was Rosen could be
Rosa's agent what was Rosen's it could
be maintenance agent maybe they hear
that Browns want to go one week abroad I
mean that's a big difference in payday
from the number one draft pick to the
number give me millions that every year
there's some that's a little piece of
information that gets dropped the day of
the draft every [ __ ] I don't know why
Josh Alden go it's rap lyrics I grew up
unwrapped there was a rap lyric I like
what he did which is just like hey man
you know he took him down just so no one
can keep going back and like bust his
balls about it and he's like [ __ ] it
they try to kid senior I know let's look
at everybody else's social media when
they were [ __ ] 16
everybody put there by the way every
calkins saw has had social media their
entire life yeah every kid yeah now on
every human being that gets drafted will
have it all the girls there
hook up with in high school although
everything was it who was the kicker
that went nuts and it was so funny and
everybody was trolling the Cowboys that
was great during the draft but he goes
when this guy was draft
the last time and the Cowboys won the
Super Bowl where Super Bowl yeah
everybody weren't even born yet yeah
everyone in this dress wasn't even born
yet this is true but that's a good
zingers was his the drop before I love
to kiss titties wait what your zach is
he 2011 2011 I have a question for you
who doesn't babies love to kiss titties
even lesbians yeah I have a question for
you guys and what you do I mean I
understand he's about uncommon II know
it's football related okay I love Ryan
shazier coming out but Tim actually got
him in the NFL I was I did do that he's
mad that knowing that he didn't thank
him isn't it a little bit a little bit
if you were a draft pick like to look at
that and go goddamn that could be me in
five years oh yeah I mean he's only he's
only drafted four years ago oh that's a
great barely barely you call that walk
in I rewrite you're like I mean you know
I understand the symbolic Nate that's
the first time we've technically really
seen him and you've always heard oh he's
doing good at the Super Bowl
nobody here but remember from like nine
months no one said [ __ ] now I couldn't
really even get any reliable news that
was like he's okay he's doing good you
didn't know like he may never walk again
you didn't know how Tribeca poetry no
I'm not gonna run the light by three
months but I am gonna do this okay I I
did that episode of the league where I
went to we had a dream secrets at the
combine and Ryan shazier was one of
those dudes and they've shorted episodes
by far top in the top twenty least okay
these favorite I know by far dude I mean
you're talking it was Carlos Hyde
the Michigan tailor LaJuan yep there was
Mike Evans yep yep the most feared guy
out of all those guys Ryan shazier by
far the fear beer - what well yeah bad
breath no athlete wise like the guy that
everyone was like you would not want to
run into that guy oh just physical
specimen yeah unbelievable and just to
see him now I mean you look at
everything just make early for air he
was I mean he looked like if he could
just stay healthy and don't have him
there that day I'm just saying like as a
draft pick I'd I you know even you just
go [ __ ] dude how depressing was the
draft overall I mean what channel I
didn't really watch I was [ __ ] I was
one of my 10,000 Little League games
during I'm watching it you know on the
phone I just I saw when the Giants got
Berkeley that's all I wanted so Adam and
I were texting nobody got will Hernandez
in the second round which I very nice
Haman solder Manning up a cowboy or
Giants fend Adam you know he's a giant
so we were excited very excited I got my
baby on the way
Manning up right this year they come
straight up and down they got it all off
let them check it down that's all you
got a little bit the Browns will look
back on that and be like I mean we I you
could only pray as a human being that
the Browns picks work out I mean I I'm
not even Browns fan I love the city of
Cleveland I think it's completely
underrated you have to hope this work
cuz this is so bad
their picks were so bad that I pray that
they work out they were talking with the
GM of Cleveland and I was very against
them I mean sure I thought they should
have taken Berkeley they should exactly
right then when they didn't do that
everybody's like take job who's like the
best and but they but baguette neither
of them is unforgivable but then I read
that they got this press coverage
coroner from Ohio State who's the best
corner in the draft and you go that's a
bit of a reach you know everybody had
him in like 10 but then they go weird he
had
who's a defensive player they got last
year yeah and they go and watch all of
the footage of him who's basically jobs
at peppers peppers no no he was their
second rounder but anyways he every time
he gets to the quarterback a second late
like he's got he's free but he gets to a
second cuz he can get the ball off
because there's no coverage you know I
mean they have to let him hold the ball
longer so we needed the best corner
because we already have job yeah -
Garrett that's miles Gary yeah
miles Garrett they're like if you were
and they go 20 times we have footage of
Garrett getting to the quarterback right
as after he let the ball go you know
like it would have been a sack if we
would had better coverage and I was like
okay I don't think about [ __ ] like that
but know that meant does make sense you
see now stronger secondary even though
he's the best player on the board he
wasn't as I need for them because they
already have him well I I get you add a
little bit we'll see I always thought
about like well remember when the Texans
had Damian clowny and they were like oh
you're gonna GJ Watt and he has never
trances their inability to get a
quarterback they finally got going last
year but then again he gets hurt yeah so
I mean like I hope I just hope I didn't
attack you to be alright I mean there
are people that made a mistake not
taking a quarterback I do think that
especially if you look at Eli statistics
going down obviously the last four or
five three more years to 3 or 2 or 3 X 5
you just can't pass on a generational
running back like this dude this guy to
be your Walter P then I'll [ __ ] sit
here good analogy that could be that but
that also could be your Walter Payton
for the next 12 or LTE literally oh I
couldn't be happy I think it with a
Heisman talk I bet you would
last year I was blown away that he
didn't make the finals for the Heisman
talk yeah perfectly they got that kid
from Stanford made it which was weird
yeah I mean he's just so versatile and
like every scout saying like he can't
find a hole in his game that's it drop
the ball
doesn't fumble it did the guy say be a
plane hole because it has any of the
running backs from San Diego say ever
done be Marshall Faulk that's it but
like recently they've had some amazing
running backs and I just wonder if
they've done anything in the NFL result
Ephraim Humphrey got Pumphrey God
TC ult went to school Ronnie Hillman
went to Pumphrey got hurt like the first
week of training camp last season Oh
last season so anything and did another
guy come out this year cuz there was
another murderer in that running back
position I don't know I state finally
getting good teams I have no clue why
that there they're not the place you
want to go all the time USC and UCLA
just suck up all Southern California I'm
sure good football player did my Herm
Edwards go there I think John Fox Munoz
yeah yeah yeah I went to zero games in
five and a half years yeah because they
all sucked
where do they play at Qualcomm Stadium
where the Chargers used to play really
still play there now this that's what
they do
yeah they renamed it they should call it
call credit unions yeah you know what
else is his stadium Oakland Oakland
Raiders Shore Coliseum college teams a
[ __ ] well it's not really their
stadium anymore a year for two years it
is when you guys bounce ah I think I
think it's like one more year than we go
high that's why I thought I don't think
I think it's not I think you got this
year and next year yeah you go you move
when the Raider when the the Rams move
in to the new stadium which by the way
the Colosseum's a [ __ ] it's a
[ __ ]
that was a [ __ ] well you know any
19th season they moved to Vegas I mean
you're after next yeah yeah so this is
two years it's a years in Oakland two
years in Oakland you have eight yeah
sixteen games in two years
well it says yeah it says the 2019
season so should just be the 2018 season
right this year and then there the next
season there and really mean that's what
this says that yeah or the 2019 seasons
yeah
one more year Teebs look for Georgia in
football what's that what's your photo
your college football team uh college
football team I don't really a ball stay
really ball state where I said UNLV how
many but how many balls have you guys
been to uh linebacker from from Georgia
I don't know much about him I got to
talk to Tiana Oh what Sony Michelle over
the other guy God the Bears got no the
Giants got the one from Bo oh yeah the
other guy yeah that's Georgia really
good
Georgia's new coach man he can recruit
he's got the number one quarterback
recruit both years and wrote like if you
if you are number one player in me in in
high school football you're the number
one quarterback why would you go rate
where last year's number one well then
the one kid transfer Eason or whatever
who is like the knowing like the year
the two years of a lot of data system
[ __ ] though what what kind of system are
you running a lot of that is I you know
that also where you live like yeah you
want to stay close to Georgia maybe you
don't want to stay at Georgia or maybe
you're like [ __ ] that kids your college
team football I've really we didn't we
didn't have one growing up see it was
like I like Notre Dame attention I was
born there sorry root for the big ten
I'm hotter damn what team would leave a
the Big Ten or big Rutgers are now and
I don't even know where they are now
Connecticut I mean Big Easy I used to be
I cried named ESPN dude they ruined the
Big East I'm so glad nobody watch their
records in the Big Ten
yeah they want New York City yeah that's
crazy that's what they wanted they want
New York City and records in New Jersey
plus they also wanted a big 10 win New
York cities in the big 10 no that's it
that's the closely the major team they
could go I was saying they wanted to be
in the big 10 when like I'm gonna kick
ya [ __ ] the ACC got Syracuse although I
you could argue they're more of the
city's team and Rutgers at least I mean
a lot of people in the city right like I
mean college kids from the city go up
there st. John's is like yeah they've
never been able to like it's not really
a school it's like just a bunch of
[ __ ] like office what st. John yeah
yeah it's like that's that's why they
can't get any real [ __ ] going you think
New York City should be able to get like
a good recruits and everything but they
can't that's was the whole thing like
Chris Mullin came back and was like I'm
gonna start to you know try to keep some
of this guy some of these guys here
instead of going down to Caroline oh
dude wherever the [ __ ] they go down well
it's very interesting because they
didn't have a great season what's that
smile for dude I know I was just looking
at my notes I was laughing about that
video that kid punching his brother but
we couldn't find I found it I fight it
yeah I got an iPhone
we are they dancing big it's
back-to-back big windows they were he
was there right Duke back to back he got
a team that could win yeah these could
yeah consistent exactly and the Big East
was tough this year with Villanova was
[ __ ] tough
villalobos great dude anytime my biggest
win tournament I think it read that name
they should just bring it back to AC or
whatever huh American Atlantic copy
Big East go back to it I know so but
it's a stock ESPN they ruined that dude
and that's why I love that's just
disintegrating and that coverage now
that Fox is doing it I will never watch
the draft on ESPN again I mean this guy
gets drafted they're showing wedding
pictures oh no I watched it on Fox
Sports go and I had a fantastic time
yeah it was
those [ __ ] human interest stories
every now and then you'd be like hey you
know both of his parents died in a fiery
car crash that's fine well how did you
know that what's his name was the
biggest baby born in Oklahoma was 12
pounds six ounces that year yeah but I'm
not talking about like this guy's
neighbor had cancer she was a little
girl like his neighbor I don't give a
[ __ ] it's just too much time that's too
much deep cancer gave it and it's the
same story it's like okay he took care
of his siblings we get it they don't
have parents you know well like honestly
I know I did the wedding thing was the
most [ __ ] obnoxious [ __ ] I've ever
heard because they basically said he
wants to be a better man because his
wife is such a good person it's like
it's outreach just to make that money
[ __ ] you be plowing for watch it I
want to say to get that money you know
what it is it's this notion that they
think like that whim the for chicks
watching the second round that's an
outreach to women
that's exactly I wanna hear that [ __ ]
Dana watches ESPN or whatever is odd
she's like why is this chick talking why
is she talking let Michelle Beadle talk
Michelle Beals fine and dude yeah all
these hot light-skinned chicks doing
like sidelines before you guys get
[ __ ] thirsty dude they got thirst in
their eyes those girls have them like if
you're a sideline reporter and you got
like genetics superfreak
multi-millionaires want to sling dick at
you Oh question whether you need this
job or not guys yeah what is the end is
this amends to a meet yeah that's what
ends yeah it's like hey guys we're you
guys gonna be tall boy for the Victoria
Secrets so you can't eat anybody's ass
you got if they want ya you can't you
can't eat it
you just gotta hang out be cool here's
your $6 an hour job here you go guys
real quick I just remembered a gig I
forgot to plug almost bad I'm in spoiler
alerts this weekend all weekend long and
Groot and Thor died in a New Avengers
movie
that's socks I actually haven't seen it
but that's cool but Louis hasn't gone
that cutter cannot be true that's what
I've heard I heard that how nice why
this nice way to save a dick no no I
mean I've heard a lot of things ruined
it for me dude the ESPN rot though it
started with like outside the lines
right remember he used to just be like
one bobbly alone there's a dirty side of
sports maybe I'll talk about it is any
don't care all right I'll do that but
then it's like it started when they had
to like make it when they made it into
the Today Show that's when it started
when it because like top that work suit
but interviewing when it became to view
I'll tell you when that happened when
Disney took it over oh yeah
Disney completely other kind of story
because I remember a second right
the second ABC bought it outside the
line started to do these kind of soft
stories about families and stuff and
then it just I remember you know I loved
them and it but I remember being the
first person is like one of the first
people sucked in those summer things
they did to my wish stories where they
have like on like a handicapped caterer
they have and I remember you loved it I
remember crying all summer long they did
these like 31 stories URL so there's no
Gyumri or throw up I don't think you're
- I have to five defaults remember when
I told you about my friend that used to
eat frozen cat [ __ ] wait a second
timeout dude why are you doing that
don't switch it to that now he ate
frozen cat you want a subject now what
like break the show commercial break
it's 1204 is a good time for a
commercial it is like in like a like a
sort of a cylinder shape and then anyway
he was I sense you would like suck it
like he was sucking his finger right hey
no need for that Sam so we had this guy
who got crippled and now he can barely
walk
we don't say crippled you know crumpled
crumb pump okay
I'm just super sad but you know ten
people die a year from boxing died what
do you mean they die it's like boxing
talks about that and it's like it goes
back to my theory that you're the media
who reports on your support dictates
like the the vibe of the sport the
feeling of the sport you're saying last
year ten people in box an average ten
people died that's what my box area
friend from that approximately 500
boxers have died in the ring as a result
of boxing since the Queensbury rules are
introduced in 1884 so died rate so
that's not ten a year well 500 divided
by whatever that is just in Queensbury
live other people in a hundred and fifty
years five so it's like about five a
year it's got a list actually of all of
the names here and the people and what
happened to them so when the last one
but nobody's crying for boxing to be
safer nobody's dying for
he's boxing coming to an end or boxing
won't be around the way they are in like
football and then you got baseball your
steroids are everywhere a mistake well
it is 53 football player hundred percent
a hundred guys on a practice team and
that's just in the pros well that's not
college Jesus thousand you're telling me
you think there's more football players
and there are boxers yes not even close
across the country across the world yes
a zillion percent more Bob how many high
school boxers did you know there's tons
of them we knew when you were in high
school you know a bunch of onto the box
I knew fifty people on the team and I
knew there are t-bones of boxers so you
knew 55 cities got tons of boxers all
over the world
when you're when you were in high school
how many football players did you know
there's gotta be [ __ ] when you were in
high school how many football players
did you know I did I know yeah a handful
how many boxes did you know zero yeah
but dude death doesn't take it everybody
says exactly what we just said this is
some random-ass forum in 2011 someone on
the website answer bag said they're
around 20,000 active professional boxers
worldwide yeah well why there's way more
boxers maybe just because it's worldwide
how many football players are there
worldwide no football players Canadian
Football League American well this is
professional no ok what Canadians see
haulage college is professional guys how
many people are earned cardio boxing
classes triple throw cardio boxing class
they're not yeah anyone seen Billy
Blanks lately yes severe head trauma
right thank you from taking air punches
well this is people who played football
in the last seconds went along damn it
Johnny
I mean I don't I think there are fewer I
mean if it's 20,000 is the number for
boxing they're definitely fewer folks
wait what's your point
boxing people sign up and know it's a
combat sport it's combat you know but
football they think it's patty-cakes
well no but it's a lot we've got like
your sort if or deaths from
professionally playing the sport how
many cuz people that have been [ __ ] up
from playing college football all right
yeah they're probably now more football
players but they're saying injuries from
the sport that are permanent or life
threatening and no one considers boxing
like the sneaky sneak up CTS right
exactly
it would be like horse is a word DT
eSports football soccer is a sneaky but
how many who thinks no but no they go
into Hocking go dude I can't believe I
have pains and aches it's like it's hot
now but I'm right hey what you're
literally getting punched in the face my
point yes is that there's this like this
[ __ ] movement but they've always
known really long football because of
all these injuries yeah you don't
with boxing and what I'm saying is it's
and it's the same thing with baseball
and the steroid abuse it is the media
that pushes this narrative
yeah but how your sport is covered
determines how people [ __ ] see it
whereas in UFC or even NFL someone gets
busted for steroids
it's like okay on to the next one in
baseball it's like this guy got caught
[ __ ] diddling kids like it's the end
of fun now that's a that's a different
thing those steroids you're bringing in
something totally different
my point is same coverage of how of how
the meet of how that that sports how
your media covers you determine I know -
I know three boxing media guys Dan
Raphael yeah so it's like yeah moment of
silence to be like that said and they
move on they don't like the NFL and the
ESPN espy is the dumbest [ __ ] station
because they just pound on the NFL and
that's their [ __ ] cash cow and
they're just like trying to [ __ ] knee
cap it kneecap and kneecap and I'm not
saying that we shouldn't cover the
kidding that's the NFL lied for so long
about it boxing is always on that this
is dangerous you're risking your life
the fight mommy hospital like it's like
her dedication I question when I gotta
move and I said to my mom when I went
right when I came out of you what did
you do two hours later a podcast grab
the baby
Steve's creep of the baby out pads on my
nipples so I don't link in here
nipple poker I woke up today so he was
like I can't leak there Oh
hats can be used for pee diapers - hello
parents advice he's already ready to
walk off the show
she's such a punch drunk already last
week and do this with my camera so
everybody can see you recorded Monday
[Laughter]
nobody was here last week of doing
that's by recording on Monday I was my
gigs I'll blame I'll play magical I just
built breast milk out there yeah blame
magic I blame you at all can we not put
her on camera I don't know cuz that big
no no no camera little puke he's the shy
one she sleeps well in the night but
like all day like she eats once an hour
but like it was the night I wake her up
cuz I'm in pain cuz you know they get
Mary Queen law max we love max we're so
excited hours straight [ __ ] yeah yeah
she's great two weeks old
are you alright ruining your baby oh I
wake her up I'm like my boobs hurt best
yeah can we bring up that again I saw
that you had you were at a baseball game
Sunday wondering about this Barbie we're
waiting on it we're gonna get it done
well it was like other brings up a good
point because when you're going to New
York soon right
yeah I'm gonna go for the US Open and
that's when is that Oh that'll be good
you'll be watchin yes because why what's
going on well we're gonna have a
barbecue before I leave awesome yeah all
very good show me how to work a grill
the savages well no because O'Neal and
Danis I'm trying to do I have enough to
our 14th annual I'm 14th annual Music
Fest weight-wise people it's just more
to eat than you I've only owned the
place for three years well I mean it's
we've moved locations to all the
different places I've lived well
probably but the best is the skate park
because once we figure out how to drain
the pool and now it's a big skate park
for the kids but and I just want to
announce we're having a drummer
competition can you play drums would you
like to try do you want to learn it
starts at midnight when is the US Open
when is it Father's Day weekend in June
Father's Day weekend we are having a
drummer competition $500 dad how to play
drum $500 entry fee we have the drums
bring your own sticks we just had a baby
right yeah I got to pay my rent and
she's also gonna be there so everybody
pay attention that father's done me
write that down Father's Day I don't
actually know nice of you to offer when
you're leaving I know I wasn't I did it
he actually did but yeah 14 can you all
get it out our 14th annual and guys as
always I mean do you want to make a
little money you sure you well go to bed
dsi dot-com and maybe you can put some
money down on your little league Ponzi
scheme yeah going on I should let them
know about that you should let them know
about somebody's dad's a board I mean
they would gamble on it I use the code
punch 25 they get you 25 $3 to gamble
with and you can bet on NBA playoffs how
about MLB going on old strongest [ __ ]
right now Yankees and nobody got the NFL
first run you know if you bet on the
whole first round
throw in a buck get the whole first
round right win a million Oh
really no draft yeah you got a guest
trade you got to do everything but yeah
it's the trade if there's no trades it's
even hard to do yeah but with trades you
really got a really so but no one did
that I but I did notice that but you can
I bet yeah NFL guys couldn't get that
thing done right absolutely not I mean
yeah yeah Arthur Blank [ __ ] anybody
you know nobody any of the GM's
to meet you off nobody could but you can
bet on everything you have she was
coming up the big steep a fight coming
up that's right yeah yeah that's coming
up that's gonna be fun but use the code
punch 25 if that gives you 25 free bucks
to gamble with and throw it put a
hundred bucks in there guess what they
double it put a hundred in they put it
on hundred in and that's from your
friends at punch-drunk I want to hold
the baby I'll be back baby I'm so stoked
you're here I literally assumed you
wouldn't be so you're good how's
everything yeah but I didn't want to
spoil it last night when you asked how I
was so I just responded the photos cuz I
was like they they're not be recorded we
were talking about them on the show
today of how bad my boobs that's fine
I've seen him everybody literally live
so I'm so stoked you're here this is so
cool
they spray her in the face it's pretty
funny to watch her face when they're
getting sprayed in the heads with with
milk this is how I woke up this morning
that's just bread what am I looking at
do you see how like all the darkness is
that your own no I hanging on the crib
drying now from what because that's boob
felt like I was soaking wet
oh I got you I got you yeah yet that was
me all the time but it's usually come in
tears that's a lot I was just like woke
up I have that much Tears income that's
a lot that just looks like breast milk
to me that much come in tears is like
mmm
that's quite a what something ain't
right sorry call today did you hear the
new no he's in Australia and he's all
did you hear the new of course not
you're a busy but the patreon I told the
funniest story there's 11 minute clip
that came out last
oh did you see that yeah I haven't
listened get crazy ass story no it's
literally like the dumbest like it's
typical Tebow the dumbest [ __ ] way to
[ __ ] yourself
so I'm hooking up with this girl I'll
tell the story real quick well
everybody's outside with a baby I'm uh I
meet a girl she's really cute exactly my
wheelhouse Jewish everything you know
sex ever do you realize they only they
like me I just like who likes me they
are the ones that like me so
everything's going fine and dandy and we
meet one time kind of a cop and then she
hits me up she's like hey are you gonna
be at the comic store and I'm like yeah
I'm doing a podcast of doing the patreon
okay oh cool my friends want me to come
meet them there and so I'll be there too
- maybe we can hang out afterwards I'm
like great so I'm there early and
Johnny's right on time typical punch run
Johnny's right on time I'm half hour
early yeah he's like 15 minutes late and
so I go to the bar I'm talking to Toby
am I having a [ __ ] cocktail and
nobody's out on the patio it's you know
cuz it's kind of like yeah yeah yeah
that kind of thing all the shows are
like primetime but there's these three
you know nice my age like black guys
sitting at like one of the tables out
there and they're talking about what's
on the TV above me which is old 1980s
NBA Larry Bird Magic Johnson that kind
of [ __ ] and I talk about Larry Bird and
just cuz I'm bored and I have no one to
talk to I go up to him I go [ __ ] a
lot of people forget how good Larry Bird
was I mean he was like only person ever
BGM of the year coach of the year NBA
Finals MVP and season MVP no one's ever
done all that like like yeah yeah
then we get to talking I'm making them
laugh I'm kind of kitchen commentating
that kind of
it and I'm like [ __ ] me I'm looking at
my phone like what time it is and he's
like hey what's wrong I'm like man I got
this [ __ ] little dime piece coming
through tonight and she's like super
[ __ ] cute but she looks exactly like
somebody that everybody here would hit
on and now I got a B I'm about to go
down and do this podcast downstairs and
then I'm gonna come up and I'm gonna
come up and everyone's gonna be hitting
on her
and I'm like but she's [ __ ] hot as
[ __ ] I'm definitely gonna try to [ __ ]
spray her down and I you know I'm doing
this kind of [ __ ] yeah so then triple e
comes in about Candice really comes it
Triple E comes in and he goes you know
you finally if he shows up and he's like
hey let's go to the pod I'm like okay
and then as I'm walking down to go do
the pod I hear like hey and then I turn
around and it's her yeah oh no she goes
you met my friends those three black
guys were her friends and I just told
her everything yeah yeah it was the
worst so wait did she stop talking to
you does she know no no is she spray
down your sprayer down of course for two
days that's how I woke up two days down
yeah and it sprays her in the face it's
Grammys leaking so great we knocked out
Betty siy you're gon take the dog I do
show you had to drop it need to make
everybody leave I just wanted to we just
walked out on you I'm so happy that was
the coolest thing ever that was great
thank you
babies are great if there are you uh
join being a mom yeah it kind of cool it
just like really does come natural it's
weird I'm just like oh this thing is
here now yeah never leave just like part
of it yeah she's gonna be with you to
the end yeah you got the way your baby
loves kissing titties you got no choice
or your babies Mitch to Biscay by the
way the Bears had a fantastic draft as
well he's the Bears quarterback that's
something he tweeted we know well I'd
like the kiss yeah [ __ ] moms have you
seen how hot she is I'm at the age where
the moms are bangable oh no
over there yeah I think you're after you
like I was talking to a girl Steve I'll
tell ya I was talking to a girl at the
combination nice nah he's cute you spray
her down with another no no hose her off
yeah she gave me that that that's been
punched like everybody man it feel yes
reaction like napalm ur ring training
his mom you'd bang him yeah I would talk
about he's got a face
I totally bad dot dot dot yeah yeah down
my bad go on tell your story
I don't remember what no we turned my
being you're saying I'm I'm at the age
where I [ __ ] a mom I was talking to a
girl ran I wasn't trying to hook up with
her but she's like oh hold you and she's
like I'm like 45 sec my dad's 45 and she
was legally there drinking my dad's my
age and I'm like wow that's you know
right right right it's weird how does
that feel not good
awful it feels awful I want to take it
back and not have that via thing that's
how you are are you watching the
playoffs NBA playoffs at all yeah I am I
was well I've watched it missed last
night's games we are in a new era like
you can tell like the LeBron James era
and those guys are starting to fade out
what's the new era do Aaron yes are you
not watching I mean I don't have a dog
in a fight what so every game I feel
like it's all this thing they're gone
he's been watching every game well yes
it's very interesting cuz Rozier is like
killing it right now and then you gotta
ask yourself if you have Rosie Rose
putting up huge numbers and Kyrie gets
hurt
do you move Kyrie do you move them to
another team to try to get a bigger ass
yeah you know you don't even know who
that team is they I mean their kids are
on the door yeah you don't you like we
haven't even seen the Celtics that the
Celtics bought Yeah right
we haven't seen that yeah so you got to
give them a year to be
yourself though thing they don't move
[ __ ] next year I'll tell you right now
if anybody can figure out how to do it
to me Brad Stevens is the well when they
hired him I was like oh man they're
getting [ __ ] duped by this whole you
know mid conference guy who just you
know beretta team to enunciate
but that close to knocking coach man and
he really knows how to work that
personnel like we need up next man up
everyone on that team this gets in there
and they I mean they just keep replacing
starter after starter with their bench
players who just step up that rosy road
dude he's good next year I think he'll
be able to figure it out and they I mean
they're gonna be insane look who knows
what the East is gonna look like Nick
would you move power your DeMarcus
Cousins so straight up yeah I would I
mean you got Rozier who's killing it
he's too old tomorrow DeMarcus Cousins
too old I would if I'm Boston I go hey
man we went all in on this vision why
bust it up when we haven't even seen it
yet I give it another year or David see
what it is what I'd ask for Anthony
Davis I I don't think I don't think the
pelicans do that no they'd be done that
guy is all world and I'm I'm Sonia I
really do believe the next game will be
way more competitive than the first game
I think that the pelicans were like yeah
well [ __ ] like oh it's another level
yeah and I think I think Houston's gonna
have a real problem getting to the
championship game over over Golden State
even though I feel like they had a the
Houston a better season is because there
when you when your jump shooting team
that's great in the regular season but
literally the only jump shooting team
ever to win a championship was it gonna
say worse because they have three of the
greatest shooters ever to play fast
professional basketball I mean they are
all timers we're talked karite Iran and
and klay Thompson
so you that's the level of shooting you
have to have when you get into those
really tight tight tight games where the
pressure yes [ __ ] thick and there
because when those jump shots don't fall
what do you do and does Houston have
that because hard
King [ __ ] just start cranking out of
nowhere and cp3 is so analytical he gets
in this [ __ ] head and like when those
things aren't gonna fall what's gonna
happen and those guys are so the goal
say where shooters are so calibrated to
that basket that they can just throw
they look they throw it up and there's a
good chance if you go in yeah the
playoffs are a different animal where in
the sense that you're not gonna get on a
run like you can in the regular season
there and run off 12 to 15 games in a
row where you're playing every night
you're playing jump teams it's you're
playing tonight you're probably not play
tomorrow and everything we're doing
tomorrow is to correct everything we
[ __ ] up last night yeah the completely
game against that same thing yeah and
you're getting the best literally the
best of that team every night and the
best game plan that they can come up
with for your team so yes it is a
difficult thing that when you live by
the jump shot if harden does have one of
those games like he did in the last
series he went three for 20 for one game
you know they're not you know I don't
you know I love I will have Joe Elam be
down low or someone that can go kick
into cousin I would love LeBron to go
seven games every [ __ ] Series win
every single time go to Game seven in
the finals win the finals again and then
here for a year what a piece of [ __ ] he
is and what a loser he is he came out
for two minutes yeah lebrons some
lebrons sake says he sucks who says he
sucks who says he sucks who LeBron yeah
you don't hello LeBron's not top-ten for
you
I say seven dude you'd be like that
seven offensive thing in the [ __ ]
world is one boy or at least and hat I'm
sorry dude
you have [ __ ] selective memory hold
on is everyone you have above them
finished right there's no active players
above him nope no active players well
that's okay then I mean he's not
finished yet thank you I hear it you
want to hear it
well I'm sure yeah Kobe's in front of
him no it shouldn't be no Michaels in
front of yeah yeah it goes Michael
Kareem yeah
magic Tim Duncan Shaquille O'Neal Larry
Bird then LeBron James I we could argue
a flip on Larry Bird
if you want I was gonna argue Larry Bird
Shaquille that's fine Shaquille O'Neal
do people forget young Shaquille O'Neal
absolutely he [ __ ] was he was as
athletic he changed basketball everybody
had to draft different everybody above
LeBron had to go through a much harder
conference to get to the finals what
happens to LeBron is he goes through
nothing then gets through finals and
that's why he plays his first [ __ ] he
changed basketball Matt LeBron so he did
not I mean I hated hated do you think he
is I don't think he's hated I think
there are people who are going to like
when you guys forget these times in
Dallas when he had he's in the finals
and yeah he could have a triple-double
and then the next game completely
disappear but if somebody's in the
finals for a decade in a row of course
you're gonna have off nights
some people never make the finals he's
in every decade I would tell you dude
Larry you got a said mentally is better
than [ __ ] baby but for 10 years not for
15 going on 15 not going on 15 we Larry
Bird [ __ ] paved his driveway and
[ __ ] his whole career up my [ __ ] is
back up that's what happened that is
owned apparently that's what happened
right mind so what a heck now LeBron
smart enough to know look I mean he's
also with a day and age where he's got
like a guy that comes over at noon every
day to stretch him out and all I should
have had but he's smart enough to do
that and his body has taken way more
than Larry Bird's did for the course of
Larry Bird's ball the game is 450 not
nearly as physical as it used to be
listen LeBron dude to say if I said you
were the seventh greatest comic of all
time you'd be like thank you yeah right
I mean we're acting though I know I'm
I'm telling him he's a [ __ ] scrub I'm
picking but it's also like what people
do with LeBron and that's a good analogy
is they go like it's almost like a
Carlin were you like here's a ticket
yeah to HBO specials that weren't that
good you're like he did 11 HBO specials
two of them you have a problem with and
that's what you lead off about him dude
listen Tim Duncan
two-six finals 1/5 of them should have
won a 6-1 if pop hadn't pulled him
[ __ ] I was too great a power forward
of all time he is okay I can go through
all these guys [ __ ] Larry Bird had to
deal with Magic Johnson's Lakers every
[ __ ] time very for 7 on your list I'm
saying why do people [ __ ] on him and not
even - he's the active goat listen but
Larry LeBron James was loved until he
did that stupid Cleveland [ __ ] YMCA
thing and then he got [ __ ] on because he
he [ __ ] [ __ ] over CLE just treacly
like [ __ ] I don't think anyone had a
problem with him leave him it's how he
left and then he went to Miami and he
[ __ ] ghosted against [ __ ] Dallas
he ghosted and then he was playing San
Antonio and he [ __ ] cramped up and
then he had a [ __ ] [ __ ] series
against them he's had good series but he
has disappeared there was a moment where
everyone's like LeBron doesn't like
taking the final shot that was a running
theme do you remember in the all-star
game we're going down where Jordan can
play defense I'm yeah running themes and
everyone's always became a defensive
player of the year
yeah right right right or first team
defensive player right well up until
last year and this is where he goes from
four to [ __ ] seven is that game five
against Golden State
he's not covering [ __ ] KD and you
could say whatever you want everybody
above him would have [ __ ] taking
their challenge like if I'm gonna go out
I'm gonna go out try I would have come
when the guy in your position
magic wouldn't have covered him 100%
maybe not great but he would he got an
on him no they would have put a
specialty guy on and the Lakers had
those specialty guy Magic Johnson never
ran from any [ __ ] challenge no he
played every position but I would
consider him like Richard Jefferson on
[ __ ] KD as he's covering five I don't
even know who the Brawn was covering
Howie
so he's about it why are you so upset
about it
I didn't see you at all I never once
said Sam why is this I'm a wideband
people I brought it wisely last Lionel's
currently hunger the guy crit I mean so
that's that ruins his legacy his legacy
but no Jason it's not just that when you
add it to the other things then it
becomes a [ __ ] pattern it's not just
one time and if you're telling me all
this guy gets the files all the time and
he loses more and yes not every time did
he have the best team but there were
times where he lost the finals where he
had the better team and he didn't say
just mentally he didn't have the killing
instinct and it's fine he's number seven
it's not if I even said you were that
seventh best player best comic at the
Comedy Store right now that would still
be amazing but it would also still be
your opinion yeah that's all that's all
this whole show is yeah yeah there's a
there's nothing like what my point is my
point acts nothing against you I never
once said Sam Tripoli you do this my
question was why do people not talk
about him as the act of goat it should
be a given but you watch every [ __ ]
show every [ __ ] thing everybody has
your things but they eventually show
reaming about him how Katie's better or
if someone feels better or ganas better
or someone else is better than like
whatever that is I'm tired yet well
people to me hired a sad story it's why
the heisman guides so hard for a heisman
guy to repeat you see Heisman people the
Heisman winners hat win the trophy in
the next year Siskel you have a better
[ __ ] year and they don't get any rub
it's a Mighty Mouse it's like Mighty
Mouse everyone talks about how boring is
long as title defense not the cartoon
but to fight
of course ok I was like ok nobody here
remembers that car we're doing some UFC
talk I mean she came all the way here
and then we'll talk NBA it screamed when
we walk why would you yelling about NFL
so it was funny because he's like so so
I know you don't know why do people
respect my bond [ __ ] you TiVo for I
never said that away I never once said
anything about
why did [ __ ] but it's like Minnie
Mouse tell everybody in that division
talk [ __ ] about who's great I'm like but
no one's taking the belt from the champ
yet he still is the best sure he might
be the most boring just be sure he
doesn't sound ranted but it's the same
thing right and well there's a couple
things his division is more way more
like it's a newer division it's not that
deep you can't compare who he's fought
versus equally to who Jon Jones has
destroyed no I'm comparing him to LeBron
he's been the goat for so long that
everybody's like he's eventually gonna
retire let's talk about what the future
is gonna look like yeah well it depends
on what it means to you you want to win
one game tomorrow you gotta wait one
game tomorrow yeah and this guy that you
picked your draft picks gonna score the
most points for your team right and
guard the best guy on your team who you
takin one game I already told you I'm
taking little Jordan no I'm talking
right now active oh I mean LeBron's me
too they're exactly these they're but
yeah you're gonna take Katie to play
defense
III dude I mean I can't he's gonna he's
gonna tease gonna guard whoever you
don't take you want to take LeBron I'll
take LeBron I'm not saying I wouldn't
take LeBron I'm just say I'm Jason over
maybe any day the week other people I
definitely love [ __ ] I mean a kid from
Milwaukee would be the only person I
would consider taking over just
unbelievable I love that guy yeah and I
if I if we're drafted I had third and he
fell to me I feel I feel good I do here
i watch him push LeBron around I walk
that's what I'm saying no he's okay so
but for a whole year if you want to
build a team you got to you got to think
about that guy over LeBron because I
mean did anybody watch that fade or if I
and Frank Mir fight I did no I did you
don't do belly to highlight you're just
strictly your free that was rampage
yeah no no as Risa it was the beginning
of this tournament that was the only one
that's when he fought his rampage first
round yeah yeah I watched that one but I
didn't watch this weekend and I remember
there being fights on and I was like
who's fighting and I won't see UFC but
yeah I was like hey dormir
on paper I mean you know your fights I
think mayor would run away with that
based on what faders John and where he's
bigger name what happened at all
III love Frank Mir he's won I met him
he's a nice guy same ah yeah I mean hey
doors just got that if he can get his
hands on yeah he does car look good the
highlights from this card ID which is
all that I've seen all I've seen where
all the highlights oh you didn't want
you there no no I just only saw the
highlights because I was watching boxing
that's like that's like reading a book
but you're skimming you're skimming yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
but it's that's when I was watching
boxing and we went to go do that pod so
I watched all the HBO boxing instead of
this I actually forgot it was on but I
watched all the height of some fact that
was a good card like every fight was
like submission knockout you a belt or
and it's knocked out by fader and you're
like oh wow [ __ ] who knew belters
problem is if you don't get the
paramount network that's called now
which is the worst name I which was what
it was bike it's just like a dice on
paramount I'm like I don't even know if
I have that I know that's was right yeah
it's just a stupid name and if you don't
get the channel you can't see the
flights and if it's good I mean I really
do believe how did fade or went by
Felicia
it was uh it was that uppercut II coddle
the guy's got he's got like that [ __ ]
that ghetto country [ __ ] strength you
know hood farmers and a guy look he does
he look like he ever doesn't sit up he's
just like like a farmer strong dude
he'll he's always in the game always in
the game what was he like a cop or
something right no that's Marco cro cop
oh who was like a Ukrainian cop right no
yeah so it's just like he's crazy and
like dude like nobody talks about I
think some people do but Fey doors in it
like when he was in the pride he was
fighting all those monsters and
everybody was juicing which I
I think they should be allowed my pride
was basically like baseball in the early
90s and WWF always that's what pride was
got it they would drug test you but they
wouldn't tell you if you flunked or not
and then if you tried to leave that be
like ah but you had all these flunk
tests if you leave we're gonna let
everybody know you failed a bunch of PDP
oh really I didn't know I don't know the
yeah I think it was the Yakuza that
rabbit is what that is true yep that is
true really you guys see that under the
giant doc yeah pretty cool right I'll
watch something like the first oh yeah
three minutes we found something that
talked about
it was crazy right yeah you know you
don't think about him be on a plane you
don't think about him not being able to
go into a restroom on a flight for
someone that took 300 flights a year
yeah long ones to those back like he
said those long flights back then we're
knocking he wasn't flying from Cleveland
to Denver he was flying to Tokyo to
[ __ ] Europe to [ __ ] he was on a
plane for 18 hours
yeah knocking down booze too deep I
can't I mean do it one time I how much
people cases of wine cases taking a [ __ ]
must have been the worst on a plane or
just in yeah yeah no one even got into
that like two toilets he probably
destroyed it's like you're you're for
toilets that we're just ah I mean even
if you sat here for signs playing hold
up for his pants are off yeah yeah he'd
literally have to probably stand his
[ __ ] is like your tits it's just
leaking out before now yeah where it's
even out yet it's a callback to a story
when you guys were both gone like two
shits bigger than your kid oh absolutely
did your vagina imagine his [ __ ]
today yeah every way I could
Andres you ever weigh yourself before
and after a chef just to see what that
was five at five forty five and then
five eighteen
Wow look at that yeah it was awesome I
mean I had no idea how uh how like how
smart he was about like knowing the
sport and where it was going how was a
big show and like how he would play
along with it
but then also his bad side his [ __ ]
side where he like when someone else try
to act like could be the tough guy he
would just [ __ ] slap and how like
everybody like Big John Studd they said
like Hogan Big John said he's like ah
he's gonna go with you brother bro like
I do Randy the Macho Man side scared
everybody was of him like all these guys
at week sitting with it don't don't talk
to Andre exactly and how they were just
so now there's a move that that Randy
the Macho Man Savage is dad and Vince
McMahon didn't like each other oh really
there was like big hatred because of
what I probably just [ __ ] the
McMahons are scumbags like I loved
watching how they yeah they kind of let
Vince McMahon kind of try to paint
himself like this loving God I didn't
know what to do with him when he came to
me was very sick yeah it is [ __ ] way
too much plastic surgery so I just asked
them oh [ __ ] one more fight in the wide
open Detroit not gonna get the white
Lana Richie he's the white little racist
joke then at the end he just let me hang
him something you realize what a scumbag
that guy was like he's a scumbag you
know like when's the last time you
talked to him yeah I mean I can't I
can't watch wrestling docks cuz the end
of the story is too much like comics
yeah like oh and just nobody's come and
see the shows and he was just like he
died alone in a [ __ ] hotel yet he
bought a farm somewhere it's like no
that's fine I'm cool with that it's
always like the guy that had the mansion
for like five years that dies in a hotel
[ __ ] alone later am I
be that the wrestler I was like a Mickey
York's exciting [ __ ] at a lodge I'm up
[Music]
yeah you're like I don't even have [ __ ]
to sign and like women wanted them oh
it's a other thing is you just got mean
yes I mean they didn't interview any of
the women yeah of course yeah exactly
walk they're all dead
they all died I mean these fingers are
huge size 20 size 24 ring imagine him
fisting me look at the beer and not just
me anyone I guess anyway size 24 ring
which you could get three hangers into a
yeah yeah there's that what's his uh by
the way gotta love it
horn Mean Gene are [ __ ] all three of
the dudes like they did not give a [ __ ]
about suits back then right I mean they
suits have come so far they're so nice
now it's like yeah so what do you do I
am a porn star that just says I look at
his face never had good hair though no
dude you can't do better than that ron
jeremy has out here today
yeah that is the ron jeremy haircut
today
hey let's don't cut their hands off what
the [ __ ] is that that's so creepy that
is creepy as [ __ ] over bronze oh then it
was not creepy at all oh wow of course
he has to go to Germany to get one you
want to say what no power penetrate
lieutenant I'll tell you right now
there's no Germany on this is not a porn
producer movie that I watched well at
one point I didn't I watched and
whenever I see german porn on the thing
i this there's nothing there doing over
there that I can handle I don't know
what the GG girls dude that's just like
there was a sucker born in my
neighborhood there was a sandboxed and
and then when it was winter everything
would
freeze but these cats would still [ __ ]
in it because they thought it was like a
cat box and then there was this girl we
knew we dared her to eat the slide into
it like a Snickers why would she was
like a weird little girl but it was
frozen but we're talking about just
german porn yeah she took a chunk out of
it look like that
she took a chunk out of it good friends
guys Patagonia is calm and my jackets
ready to go oh you know what [ __ ]
Johnny with some sound effects frozen
[ __ ] dildo got him laughter oh yeah with
a freezer [ __ ] Oh magic frozen Fozzie
that's not what you're supposed to know
hamburger yeah your [ __ ] I'm looking at
my ticket counts for Charlotte I'm doing
a weekend May 17th this night most your
tickets like the week of not he's like
sweating you so upset about not here I
dude I hate ticket sales I hate it too
I'm so depressed now I just saw
percentage sold oh when did the weekend
this weekend no it's in like three weeks
so you're fine
yeah it's fine I tell people buy tickets
right now I did I am but I'd like to
move off the cat [ __ ] sell some catchin
people eating it okay I would love to
have an online poll be taken right now a
people interested in this subject this
is a construct it will be probably 90%
no one is the eyes didn't catch it yeah
I'll talk about [ __ ] all day long
finger [ __ ] finger your blessing
would catch it
exactly exactly why ruin it it's a great
thing already we don't need to add cat
[ __ ] do it orc secretions I want a
sandbox that happened to me what it does
cap cat I'm allergic to cats are you yes
don't you have a cat you know I have a
dog would you guys go to
punk sports calm and click the Amazon
link that helps out your boys and also
go to caveman coffee co calm use the
code punch honk that gets you 10% off of
everything
Coffee related and everything there is
fantastic and that helps out our good
friends a pun Chuck and a good friend
tape Fletcher blue I want a challenge to
a fight
oh really good idea dude we talked about
that are you guys fighting people I ever
agree to us right except for Ari Ari's
the only one it's like in size maynia
mean yeah I think it's supposed to be
September what I thought he got the date
let me see
I must see if he got the date I would
like to officiate that fight by the way
I you're fighting right I got the main
fight which is Ryan O'Neal vs. Gomez
well that's the main fight I started
that yeah I'm like how did this come
about
I started it they're like oh I'd like to
see like Gomez versus uh I think it was
Ari I'm like [ __ ] that yeah Gomez versus
Ryan O'Neal is the [ __ ] fight Gomez
fight I don't know oh I guess can he act
like he can yeah Ryan can yeah well
Gomez is crazy enough to go for it Ryan
Silas no oh [ __ ] around he's training at
the art and Louis told Mickey Gaul if he
helps him cuz that's where Mickey's
training now Joe Schilling he's like our
friendship is over
oh really yeah oh you mean Mickey gone
like it yeah I think it's gonna be maybe
in July I think make you should help us
cuz Ryan's on our side so Mick you
should train right and you yeah it's
really punch Don you're gonna [ __ ] yeah
man what a fight that's gonna be this is
so how do you feel about that fight I
feel great about it
100% yeah I mean the thing about Ari's
he's not smart like you feel smart he
actually is smart but if he was smarter
he would want boxing because he has a
giant reach over me
a giant I disagree though I think boxing
is way more to your advantage
yeah I think you're a way better puncher
than him you're throwing more weight
what I think he gets you to the ground
and makes you wind it is it all MMA
rules not to his winner great but I
think that like he uses by the way do
you remember I'm gonna block it and then
he gets to that's just my boxing is your
advantage
yeah I think he has reach if he's smart
but he still can with MMA but he also
has a leg reach he also like sorry I
can't kick I can kick
I studied Thai boxing I can [ __ ] I don't
know you can do what this is gonna be
I'm just saying if it was only boxing I
think you is it easily is it one round
51 it's five rounds five minutes
let me guess one minute I think are easy
on us he knows the judges win third game
who's supposed to be three three he went
five and he got me on five well that's
what he's trying to do he realizes if he
stretches you out yeah you're done
anyone the second one I thought you won
the third one I won the first two and he
won the third one seventy seventy
percent so our fans are savages so in
all right so then we'll talk about catch
it so we would break off it sounded like
a like a Butterfinger and she would just
suck this thing like an hour later and I
was like your dedication to this is
staggering young lady so would we not
want to be her friend just know I need
to stop talking to that girl and that
girl grew up to be poopsicle fight nanny
everybody we met over frozen pieces and
now she has a baby
do you guys remember how Frances Ngong
who fought steep a last time like he was
dying that way yeah like both of them
yeah I think that's it are you I'm so
tired in your life I think I think Ari's
gonna almost die running
20v that is true but I think I think Ari
will have a surprising amount of cardio
that we don't anticipate you know during
the basketball game he was on the ground
that's before he was hiking all the time
he lost all this weight he's doing yoga
all the time he naturally taking care of
himself in a way that we don't haven't
been [ __ ] doing boxing for a long
time if you think walking and [ __ ]
doing rounds which is an energy jump
energy dump diet you you are [ __ ] ass
before you walk in and that is just like
you get this energy dump and then you're
just [ __ ] running on fumes for the
next I didn't ari has good cardio I said
Ari is gonna have better cardio than
dinky well because we last remember him
playing basketball and on his hands and
knees puking before he like lost all
this waiting up whatever he did win the
race he's best at us athletically
recently yeah ah look at that form but I
don't know it'll be interesting I think
if it was boxing only he's aft and I
think he still is aft but I think [ __ ]
you Rich Eisen what an idiot
that was super fun I can't wait for that
again what happened what am I saying I I
think you're fine we literally bull just
said you're gonna win the fight I look
at your phone and go we're rude I'm a
mall no no nope nope nope now on top of
them ball and it's [ __ ] grinding out
my best chance is the [ __ ] just bring
him into deep waters where's that was
that yeah what hold on time out man is
that a heavy analysis that is my show
round you uh what's he's gonna do I
already know what he's gonna do dude
he's gonna rush me he's gonna try to get
me on the ground he's gonna try to hold
me down and hump me for [ __ ] three
the whole [ __ ] way that's called
bro you sound like some of these UFC
guys who want to keep it on the feet
yeah you are you want to stand up fight
already wants to get it on the ground
all right that's totally Artie's best
bet because he's he's gonna try to
minimalize me hitting him because he
doesn't like to get hit his nose is a
big tar his nose is a giant you know I'm
a counter-puncher I counter punch that's
what people say about you on the street
yeah if you watched my [ __ ] last
fight I counter punch these guys I get
in the swing boom I follow right up and
he's gonna wanna get me down hold me
down - I do some ground-and-pound and
all that [ __ ] just try to win on the
scorecards like that and then he's gonna
get dumped and then I'm gonna [ __ ]
just start throwing [ __ ] bombs
throwing bombs I mean that's gonna be
like the one he's gonna get hit once
he's gonna shut down I think there's a
chance he gets hit and if you rock him
one time I mean look he's not one I
don't know if Ari has a chin you know I
put the Jew in jujitsu oh good job like
WorldStarHipHop with two gay guys are
about the best shot look Johnny Johnny
can you pull up the kid punch his
brother thing are you gonna [ __ ] are you
ready to block it Mike if he goes down
those knees oh look at that shot right
the precious he's going for ankle are
you gonna train okay so but I mean like
beyond taking just jujitsu would you
like and like try to get your wind up I
would say like maybe run why bother
it's gonna be a quick fight rere wants
five five-minute rounds he wants the
World Championship fire Sam is the
Nagano you trained for 30 seconds is
throwing bombs and then after that
that's literally re-sing and you'll
agree what did he want I want to Bowl
you five times so all the others win one
out of five and then he brags about
winning what we talked about was like
the three
run a 40-yard dash whose runs of fastest
so the three of us did and I won the
40-yard dash but then he goes let's now
run it three times individually so now I
got a run for 40-yard dashes until Ari
gets the last time you won the first one
the three of us racing yeah okay then I
had to run three more times including
falling down once and then he finally
gets the best time and is like I won't
know thing seven years later you two
idiots figured out that his technique
against you is knowing that he has
better wind for the seven years he's
watched the two of you did you destroy
your bottle myself all of us like him
the king of hell yeah yeah [ __ ]
so he does it five Bulls you five times
we gotta race five times until he
finally gets the best five five five
right no more fives but of course I
won't even high-five that guy so today
was a great show thank you for bringing
the baby around though yeah man great
that was great
we're just a fast member when I already
doesn't show up for sure do you want and
sheep ugly show probably cries lesson re
yeah that's true
Danish Antonio listen to it it's on
soundcloud iTunes O'Neil is fighting as
you guys said Jay Gomes offense at you
are the Joe Silva I put that out you're
training at the yard with Joe Schilling
maybe are you guys on Google Play and
all that you guys got get on all that
[ __ ] oh yeah sure
yes I know you got anything done we
weren't on Google Play forever and now
you're on Google Play yeah I mean like
you have to do I don't know why all
things comedy doesn't tell you do it but
you got to do it alright oh look it's
not that hard just look it up because
like that's where everybody's got
androids and HTC and all that other
stuff that doesn't get me I see iTunes
is so interesting it's like oh here's my
ranking but just only people listen to I
firm Apple yeah yeah which Aaron says
that's most people but [ __ ] him he's
puppies partly Apple Illuminati boy yeah
that's a whole wrong
deep state yeah Aaron's [ __ ] totally
[ __ ] in on as I sit surrounded by
three pcs
I ran into Aaron at a swingers party the
other really I saw him at a jerk-off
booth his wife wasn't there buddy he was
on the receiving with me working sound
or was he just know he was there
participating no I was on the receiving
end of his Gloria was he crying crying
I've been he was when I was done I heard
he cries that [ __ ] swingers party
what gives it away that's a character
he's on the other side of the wall when
you hear the st. Louis car buff well
guys it's been fun showing sports we're
sorry as always
[Music]